when we started talking about this movie
in terms of a sense of adventure an
action sequence on a train was something
we'd always wanted to do
we wanted to build upon the previous
films and apply all of that knowledge to
something practical and real and bring
this train sequence to another level
there was not a surplus of trains
available to be wrecked we had to build
the train if we wanted to destroy it
to shoot it practically it was extremely
challenging
not just to execute but also to design
all the different train cars and it
could actually function on a working
railroad track
no one else in the world is doing this
level of practical filmmaking and it may
never be done again
the train sequence takes us an adventure
that's absolutely huge we have this big
fly on the roof going 60 miles an hour
through a real Valley
I've done fight scenes but to do them on
a moving train it was trial by fire
that's how Tom likes to do things
[Music]
is going to now pull me off the train
when you're hanging off a train Carriage
Tom's a great person to have beside you
not only is he Fearless he is always
looking to see how it's going to land
for the audience
[Music]
of multiplying factors of difficulty
we'd be chasing the train as it goes on
every single camera that had exactly one
shot at getting it right not just a
matter of going off because if we do it
all we don't capture it right what's the
point
action
everything you are seeing in this
spectacular train sequence is done to
invest the audience in these characters
Mission Impossible is the most
extraordinary Adventure franchise you've
ever seen he could only do it with a
team like this and with an actor like
Tom
[Music]
foreign